pa je pense que le françois de rugy
s'est fait un peu cette spécialité
depuis le début de ce qui vaut là il est
assis en phase avec emmanuel macron je
sais pas qui donne des consignes à
l'hôte à mon avis plutôt du côté de
l'elysée vers le parlement mais on se
souvient qu'il ya eu le vote sur la
confiance dans la vie politique c'est
c'était de cet été oui les gens qui en
réalité n'a pointé qu'une seule
responsabilité sur le problème de la
légitimité politique c'est les
parlementaires on parlait pas de
l'elysée et puis alors seulement sur
j'allais dire entre guillemets des
points qui n'était pas cruciaux nous par
exemple on a voulu introduire les
problématiques de pantouflage des
problématiques de conflit d'intérêt le
fait par exemple que la parlementaire
puisse continuer à exercer une mission
de conseil tout en étant député on
voulait éradiquer tout ça on n'a pas
réussi pas un moment dépassé mais par
contre l'espèce de suspicion généralisée
j'allais dire sur la question des frais
bon je reviens pas je pense qu'il
fallait les justificatifs thé normal
mais toute une ambiance qui est
installée et qui ne peut pas ne peut pas
être mis en eux pas été relation avec le
fait que dans le même temps je prépare
une loi qui vise à diminuer le nombre de
parlementaires donc je pense que tout ça
renforce l'aspect très présidentialise
de la vème république et que françois de
rugy y participent pourrait rappeler
qu'il n'est pas surveillant général et
vous citer un exemple qui est un très
bon exemple la question du manque de
députés lors de l'accord franco allemand
qui touchait ce fait c'est beaucoup les
dépliants marche mais il faut que
françois de rugy face le lui-même en
tire les conséquences
le parlement allemand jeudi et elle
matin d'un style sur la même question
ils ont eu le droit d'amendement le
droit de présenter des textes
alternatives dont il y avait une vraie
vie parlementaire nous dans le même
temps françois de rugy a envoyé un tacle
30 décembre
il fallait donner son accord même pas
l'amendé donné son accord oui ou non
pour le 4 janvier en pleines fêtes de
fin d'année donc tout ça n'est pas
respecté le parlement si vous voulez
plus de monde il fallait qu'ils prennent
plus au sérieux son texte et qu'il en
fasse un vrai des biens problème entre
françois de rugy et la france a soumis
par seulement avec nous faisait
remarquer un sas est unanime je pense
que françois de rugy se prend pour un
surveillant général à certains moments
je les ai déjà dit j'avais dit que
je trouve qu'il a une façon de faire par
l'ample quand tout d'un coup ils est-il
il entend un peu trop de bruit au niveau
des questions de l'actualité qu'il dit
si on continue à appliquer sont
actualisés mais c'est une méthode
brutale mais c'est au club c'est pas sa
fonction je rappelle c'est un député
comme un autre puis motion veut parler
de l'absence moi je veux bien qu'on
parle de la présence de françois de rugy
dans l'assemblée on va et qu'on le fasse
au prorata du fait qu'il a le double
d'indemnités allons-y mettant tous sont
stables l'assemblée nationale française
non je ne trouve pas non je trouve que
femme moi je suis nouveau député vous
savez donc j'ai pas j'ai pas de point de
comparaison
mais j'estime que que sa façon de gérer
les choses est très politique origines
voilà je l'avais dit à un moment donné
je trouve qu'il mérite de plus en plus
on t'aime en tout cas arrêtons avec
l'anti parlementarisme
il y compris d'ailleurs je vois il ya
des mesures et bien appliquons l'est
c'est pas la peine d'en faire dans le
faire du bruit et de laisser penser tout
d'un coup qu'il y aurait plus d'absences
un autre exemple et j'arrête là qu'on
fasse aussi en sorte que par exemple
qu'on est en commission ils puissent pas
voir que votre public en même temps on
voit il ya deux jours on se retrouve en
commission je vous rappelle que souvent
les députés que ne sont pas un mystique
je vous dis d'autant plus à l'aise c'est
que d'après des associations j'étais le
deuxième le plus actif à la fin de
l'année on est souvent en commission en
même temps c'est pas normal d'avoir un
vote public pas chivard commissions
actives on essaye d'organiser les choses